Goods Services Hospital fees Insurance
they're all priced in foreign currency
lebanon's economy has become dollarized
because the local currency is nearly
worthless
we buy everything in dollars our Goods
our rent electricity yes we should price
in the local currency but it's not
possible because its value keeps
fluctuating
trading is dominated by the black market
exchange rate
it's hovering around 50 000 Lira to the
dollar causing even more economic
difficulties for people already
struggling to get by
but it's not the only rate politicians
and bankers are accused of creating a
multiple exchange rate system to cover
up losses in the billions of dollars
banks have a big solvency problem they
deposited their money in the public
sector at the central bank and the
government and the public sector is
unable to pay them back they have this
major Gap and they are trying to shift
it to depositors through the haircut and
how do they do the hair cut through this
multiple exchange rate system it's known
as the Lawler Lebanese dollar or bank
rate and it is used to withdraw trapped
foreign currency deposits
and while the official rate has been
pegged at 1 500 liter to the dollar
since 1997 the government says the
fiscal situation means it has to collect
taxes and fees at another rate and then
there is the cyrofo rate
Sai Rafa is one of the policies
introduced by the central bank to
protect the devaluating Lira it involves
pumping dollars into the market from its
dwindling foreign currency reserves
through this exchange platform but it's
proven to be unsustainable
authorities are planning to increase the
official rate tenfold next month which
they say will help alleviate the crisis
economists disagree when you are trying
to artificially fix a the Lebanese pound
at 15 000 and everybody knows that your
central bank doesn't have any more any
liquidity because it's actually running
losses of more than 60 billion dollar
so there is no credibility to this new
exchange rate the political and business
Elite are blamed for failing to
implement reforms in the financial
sector instead they have been offering
temporary solutions that many Lebanese
say benefit them and worsen a crisis
that's now in its Force here Beirut